You didn't have the East end, the two movies and gave all of them a nine.
I really enjoyed it and have these really,
I think how we never talked about in one of these together, we never talked.
I love brings up. Never kids. No one ever brings that up. It's a great,
it's great first season,
but like the movies just didn't conclude it in the way I wanted to. But again,
both of them are nine though.
I thought you didn't have the East had one of the most interesting premises I
watched since no one talks about you didn't have the East,
we're going to sell what you do.
I remember, I, I remember my feelings for the show. I can't remember.
What happened. I have one memory.
Of this show and it was like a ship and a bunch of naked people.
Yeah. That's all I remember. None of the ending of it. Yeah.
The ending of the first season of eating of the years was great. brilliant.
What is the premise again? Okay. So,
so the premise is they have a smartphone and I can't remember exactly how much
money they were given, but he had like 13,
13 people who were given these smartphones and on a smartphone,
you have like this AI that they could request anything to happen. Right.
And they were given a budget of, I think, 10, $10 million.
It was more than that. Was it like a million or 10 million, 10 billion,
10 billion yet, which is a hundred million dollars.
So they were given a budget of a hundred million dollars and all there was
there, all they were told was to save the world right there.
That that was their objective. And so,
and so the series is just the story of these different people and their own take
on what a hundred million dollars means to save the world. And honestly,
like, I don't want to spoil what happens, but it's great.
Especially the first 12 episodes. Just go
[inaudible] it's not just, it's not just 12 episodes.
It's 12 episodes and a movie, two movies, movies. Are you sure?
Are you sure it's two movies?
Not just one because he gave both of them a nine out of 10. Okay.
But I feel like the first season was fantastic. Yeah.
It's and you know,
the problem with the first season is that it didn't conclude the story,
but the first season was fantastic. Um,
the movies were not as good in my opinion. I don't,
I didn't even know they had movies.
I don't remember much about what happened in the movie.
Some of these shows, I legitimately can't remember like fully watching.
Surprise you. What? Like you watch hint. I ordered the one on nickel,
the Stony cat and the hint IOG. I did watch that. Yeah.
You want to keep it on the audio as well?
That doesn't seem like a show you would watch.
Why have we never talked about it? We want you to black bullet.
You haven't rated it, but you've watched all of black Butler.
I remember I actually do really enjoy like, uh,
like romance slice of life shows, but I used to binge them all the time,
but not now I to black cat as well. Yeah. I blackout was though. Yeah.
The moment I watched catch him in crowds. And I remember I, that was,
I gave that a six, but that was so reluctantly. I did not enjoy watching that.
And I watched, there's a bunch of other shows that I watch after this.
I didn't include light. What's that card game, like WIC, salsa,
whatever it's called. That was.
I'm angry. I hated that. I watched that one save and watch that.
This is the thing, right? Is it to me? I didn't. I do not like looking up anime.
Like I don't want to know anything about the show, right? Yeah.
Give me the show. Let me watch it. And if I hate it.
Brain dead. Yeah. I want to read that monkey boat. Like.
Because here's the thing, right? I guarantee if you just give me a show,
tell me to watch it. I'll watch it. I might enjoy it.
If you try and sell me on a show, I immediately will stop being like, Oh,
I don't know. No.
I'm completely the opposite. I'm the opposite. Because like,
I've gotten to the point where I need to be sold on the show because I
need to have like a reason why I'm watching this show.
Like AB is the show going to get good?
Am I going to have something that I get out of this show? I, I, I need to,
I need to know that before it gets loud,
before like truly gets into a show because otherwise,
nowadays I end up dropping shows after one episode.
If it doesn't hook me even like critically acclaimed, highly claimed show. If I,
if I don't know that something good is coming up,
that's going to be worth my time that I'm just not going to give it a chance
because I just don't have that patience anymore.
I've I've sat through enough shows to know that I don't want to waste my time
anymore. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Right. Um, you know, it's, it's, it's just,
it's just sad. Cause I,
I do miss that feeling of finding hidden gems where I can just be like, Oh,
I have zero expectations.
[inaudible].
So that's an attempt if I, I haven't read that, but yeah.
I wish I, I wish I did. Okay. One, one, one thing that's curious to me,
you watch phase zero,
but you rated the second season lower than the first season. You mean the,
the,
the actual action packed second season where everything gets concluded is lower
than the first season, which is the setup. You're like,
you're like completely going against everything.
Like all the character buildup you've pulled yourself off too. Right? It's like,
Oh, I hate story. I love action. The season where there's more action.
Yeah.
I really enjoyed when they were introducing like all of the characters in fate.
That's what my favorite part. I'll fate, right?
Like fate feet stay night as well.
My favorite part of fates day night is when they introducing the characters
because it's so cool. Cause you're like, I know, I know there's an assassin.
I know there's a rider. What are they going to be? And then when,
and then when you watch fates day night, and you're like, wow, right.
His in this one compared to fate zero. Cause like fates here, you watch it.
You're like, yo rider. He's the best Alex Sando I'd him. But like,
then you watch then that's the reason why I hated fate stay night except for the
animation.
Because I was like [inaudible] which face they know what you're talking.
Yeah. The original face blade works. Okay. Okay. The series,
not the movies, right? The series. Because I'm not
[inaudible] I just need clarification because what you say fans will like on
their seat. Right. Archer. Cool. But I can't believe.
They had, like, there was no like good Alec.
They should've just brought Aleksandar back gate and be like, Hey,
I'm back baby. Or like, it's a free cool. So I guess like, Hey, I'm back.
Yeah. Cause he was like the best part.
Of zero. If I got three seconds.
He was the best part of phase zero. Yeah. Yeah. He was.
This relationship with the, uh, the weevil,
whatever it's called load the weasel waiver, waiver, whatever the it is.
I believe that's a rodent, honestly.
That's probably why.
That's what he is. Uh, what's another thing that I gave. What I don't,
I disagree with that.
There's a lot of ones that you haven't given them darker than black.
I stand by being a nine because if you watch the DOB dude, Troy bakers in that,
this is before Troy Baker stopped doing anime. I'm like, man.
He kills it as November 11.
So fun. I like talking to them.
Black is a show that I've actually rewatched quite a few times.
And I don't know why we watch it quite a few times. I've really,
I just really liked the world of dark and I'm blessed. Yeah. You know what?
I'm not going to lie. I don't remember anything.
Thought it was actually cool and weird. Cause. Cause like it was Lee.
Watching and it was like X-Men but what I found interesting was the fact that
they had to like do this really weird activity every time. Yeah.
I'd like to know smoking. Yeah. I don't know why.
I just thought that was really good. Cool. And like it has an,
a amazing soundtrack as well. Cause it was like by YOKA CARNA,
I feel like one of the biggest differences between the first season,
every other season was Yoko Connor's music.
Just set such an amazing tone for this world and this environment that it just
made. You just, it, it just felt good exploring this world and just being in it.
Yeah. It's fun, dude. I'm watching dude like the dumps really good.
I get you're saying this to Joey now. Honestly.
Honestly dude like Troy Baker is November 11th.
I love Troy biker.
So you'll sell me on because Baker plays the guy who has to smoke. Yeah. Yeah.
I've I've watched the debate as well. Oh good God.